bonsoir nous sommes le 11 décembre
bienvenue pour le 7-8 une heure pour
faire le point sur l'actualité locale de
versailles à saint quentin en yvelines
en direct à partir de 18h des
commerçants en colère contre la hausse
de leurs impôts ils manifester à saint
quentin en yvelines en fin d'après midi
vous découvrirez les images dans un
instant lors du sommaire de cette
édition mais tout d'abord bonsoir à
valérie auribeau la chronique de
l'environnement comme chaque mercredi ce
sera dans une demi heure à peu près oui
il nous recevrons la nouvelle directrice
du nouvel os qu l'observatoire
versailles saint quentin qui nous
parlera de ses thèmes de recherche
notamment la perturbation de la couche
d'ozone mais aussi du réchauffement
climatique ce réchauffement climatique
ce sera le thème de la chronique de
l'environnement à suivre d'ici une
demi-heure les titres en images à
présent les sujets à retrouver au cours
de cette édition du 11 décembre la
colère des petits commerçants et chefs
d'entreprise de pme contre l'acf la
cotisation foncière des entreprises ils
ont manifesté ce mardi après midi devant
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en plateau de
représentants nous donnerons plus
d'explications à l'association hf
prévention intervient dans la lutte
contre le sida nous vous proposons de
découvrir le travail de ses salariés
bénévoles sur un lieu de sexe comme cela
s'appelle c'est en forêt de plaisir
chaque jour entre 100 et 150 personnes
fréquentent s'attendent à un chemin de
la laïcité inauguré à guyancourt après
le rond-point des droits de l'homme la
rue de la liberté la place de la
fraternité tout cela semblait bien
logique et puis les journalistes de tv
fil 78 host ou anthony rey je vous
l'avez reconnu notre journaliste sportif
a testé pour vous le taekwondo 5 tkt 78
nous avons suivi ses premiers pas en
kimono et en ceinture blanche on débute
donc cette édition par la colère des
entrepreneurs ils s'indignent des taxes
dont il voit dont ils doivent
s'acquitter d'ici au 15 décembre des
taxes qui ont beaucoup augmenté on va en
parler
deux invités donc sur ce plateau tout
d'abord j'accomplis et bonsoir vous êtes
le vice président de la cgpme vous avez
manifesté cet après midi tout comme
laurent raux brzeski bonsoir à vous
excuser moi d'avoir écorché votre nom
vous êtes président d'acteurs
économiques amani vous êtes chef
d'entreprise vous même président de
cette toute jeune association qui s'est
monté pour justement défendre vos
intérêts ceux de vos confrères face à la
cotisation financière des entreprises
une taxe qui depuis 2010 remplace en
partie la taxe professionnelle elle a
fortement augmenté cette année vous avez
manifesté à saint quentin en yvelines au
regard des explications le reportage
d'alice gastines et de patrick jacques
de dixmude et vous nous expliquerez les
raisons de vos colères plus en détail
juste après
ils sont venus alerté les pouvoirs
publics face à l'augmentation de la
cotisation foncière des entreprises des
entrepreneurs se sont mobilisés ce mardi
devant le siège de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à trappes ils
demandent que soient recalculé cet impôt
fixé par les collectivités territoriales
et qui remplace la taxe professionnelle
vous avez par exemple une petite
entreprise un commerce qui nous
signalent qu'ils ont ils passent de
environ 500 euros à quelque chose à 4
4000 euros par exemple des choses comme
ça donc ce qui est dans un budget d'une
dune peut tout petit p tpe de cette
nature quelque chose d'extrêmement
pénalisant la confédération générale des
pme est à l'initiative du rassemblement
le but de la mobilisation obtenir le
retour au montant de 2011 à une heure on
parle beaucoup de la compétitivité des
entreprises qui est effectivement le
sujet central dans la gestion de nos
entreprises d'un point de vue de notre
économie il est évident qu'un tel impôt
dont la hauteur aujourd'hui est très
variable suivant les entreprises dont on
nous avons nous même du mal à comprendre
quelles sont les clés de calcul augmenté
de 20% pour les plus petits jusqu'à 500
600 % pour les plus grosses
augmentations c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement pénalisant pour les
entreprises donc il est bien évident que
nous ne pouvons que demander le retour à
2011 du côté de l'agglomération on
cherche une solution pour calmer la
fronde on est bien conscient que pour
certains d'entreprises petites
entreprises en difficulté ça pose
problème
voir découvrir cette application de la
taxe pro c est de cette façon là c'est
pour ça qu on a pris une délibération
que le gouvernement nous permet de
prendre pour revoir cette application de
cette nouvelle taxe tsf sur les petites
entreprises cette délibération prévoit
que les entreprises auront jusqu'au 15
décembre pour s'acquitter du même
montant que celui payé en 2011 les
conditions de paiement seront définies
lors du vote du budget de
l'agglomération mardi 18 décembre en fin
d'après midi ce mardi les entrepreneurs
ont été reçus en délégation par le
président de la communauté
d'agglomération
nous avons donc en plateau le vice
président de la cgpme la confédération
générale des petites et moyennes
entreprises également le président de
l'association une association
d'entrepreneurs à magny-les-hameaux vous
étiez sur cette manifestation l'a
entendue à la fin du reportage vous avez
été reçu par le lac lomé la communauté
d'agglomération comment se sont passées
les échanges on a réussi effectivement
obtenir
une discussion je vais dire assez
ouverte avec le président de la caisse
qui monsieur cadalbert ça nous a permis
d'arriver à faire évoluer un petit peu
les informations que l'on avait parce
que jusqu'à présent c'était extrêmement
flou il était question de faire
éventuellement une baisse sensible très
honnêtement au niveau des commerçants
des artisans des entrepreneurs baisse
sensible ça veut pas dire grand chose
quand on a le curseur qui est émis par
la communauté d'agglo à 6000 euros en
sachant que la base que nous avions
l'année dernière a été de 1000 ça nous
fait une augmentation extrêmement
importante 24 chefs d'entreprise
également concrètement cette taxe
représente quoi pour vous cette année
par rapport à l'année dernière très
simple le chiffre va être donné l'année
dernière cela représentait 307 euros
cette année cela représente 1600 94
euros
une joie dire une augmentation non
négligeable c'est le moins que l'on
puisse dire est bon certes je suis
touchée mais l'ensemble des commerçants
des artisans des petites entreprises des
indépendances ont touché et c'est la
raison qui nous a fait nous réunir des
gens courant de semaine dernière pour
essayer de monter en association ce qui
est fait nous avons fait une assemblée
constituante ce qui nous a permis de
créer cette association dont je me
retrouve président aujourd'hui et de
fait nous avons généré 7 ce
rassemblement dirons nous pour essayer
de pouvoir convaincre et de converser
avec monsieur cas d'albert et essayer de
les faire revenir à la raison vous êtes
satisfait des échanges qui ont lieu cet
après midi en toute fin d'après midi à
quelques heures oui on peut dire qu'il
ya un progrès dans le dans les échanges
d'abord par ce fait qui n est qu il y
ait des échanges tout simplement c'est
une première chose la deuxième chose je
pense que le président de l'arlberg un
pris conscience je dirais du niveau de
mobilisation
et de réaction des chefs d'entreprise
parce que aujourd'hui sa touche toutes
les entreprises c'est pas uniquement les
commerçants ou les indépendants mais
l'ensemble des entreprises sont touchées
alors sur 5000 entreprises du bassin de
lacq à skis ça fait quand même
énormément de monde et ce qui est
aujourd'hui pour nous difficile à
concevoir et à admettre c'est qu'on
n'ait tout chef d'entreprise dans une
situation plus ou moins délicate en ce
moment parce qu'en fait les marges sont
plus réduites qu'avant c'est le grand
mot de la compétitivité tout le monde en
parle en ce moment donc nous ne
comprendrions pas et les chefs
d'entreprise ne comprennent pas que ils
les entendent lorsqu'ils allument leur
télévision ou lire le journal tous les
grands titres sur la compétitivité des
entreprises et sur un impôt en
particulier avoir des augmentations qui
pour certaines sont énormes ces belles
destinations en termes de pourcentage
c'est véritablement important dépassé
par exemple autres 400 et 2000 aux jeux
d'euros à peu près aujourd'hui c'est ce
que vous allez payer toute assez de 400
à 2000 ça remet en cause la viabilité la
stabilité la pérennité d'une entreprise
alors pour certaines entreprises il est
clair que c'est absorbable mais c'est
loin d'être la majorité je peux donner
un exemple concret également qu' à dire
d'une personne que l'on est que nous
avons qui a monté sa société et pas plus
tard que l'année dernière en cours
d'année qui a fait vingt mille euros de
chiffre d'affaires et qui était qui est
axé aujourd'hui à plus de 600 euros en
sachant que 20000 euros de chiffre
d'affaires ce n'est pas on ne parle pas
bénéfice net dans les dents le chiffre
d'affaires de 20000 euros il y a
effectivement le rsi a payé il y a
également j'ai à dire toutes les charges
complémentaires il ya les impôts
également sur la société dont il reste
très peu pour vivre à la personne et
cette personne se retrouve en plus avec
une joie dire un impôt supplémentaire
qui est extrêmement élevé au regard de
jeu dire du bénéfice à la cgpme vous
avez fait ce constat également oui
nous avons fait ce constat effectivement
qui était un costume constat national et
pour ce qui nous concerne un constat
départementale il est clair
qu'aujourd'hui ce supplément d'impôt qui
nous est demandé est quelque chose de
très pénalisant pour les entreprises qui
je le disais à l'instant ont souvent des
trésoreries qui sont des trésoreries a
ses limites et si on rajoute une petite
goutte d'eau est encore une petite
goutte d'eau à la sortie ça peut faire
des ruisseaux qui peuvent mettre en
danger les entreprises et ça c'est
quelque chose de très important d'autant
plus que comme on fonctionne avec des
constantes de temps qu'ils sont quand
même relativement courte dans l'est dans
les entreprises il est évident que la
prévision
de traits de la prévision de trésorerie
les prévisionnels les modèles
économiques mais également les podiums
des trésoreries sont malmenés par ces
augmentation de l'imposition si on
revient un petit peu en arrière 5
novembre 2009 le président de l'époque
nicolas sarkozy qui annonce la fin de la
taxe professionnelle remplacée par la
contribution économique territoriale
avec deux impôts la cfe dont on parle
actuellement et puis une cotisation sur
la valeur ajoutée des entreprises ce qui
pose problème c'est la cfe elle est
basée sur les biens soumis à la taxe
foncière elle est due dans chacune des
communes ou agglomérations où se
trouvent des locaux pour l'entreprise
les communes ou les agglomérations vote
le taux justement en quoi cet impôt est
injuste aujourd'hui mais aujourd'hui mon
bail et l augmentation les chefs
d'entreprise en général
je dirais totalement les chefs
d'entreprises participent à la richesse
notamment de la casse qui mais d'une
manière générale à tous qui est
aujourd'hui des besoins des besoins de
la distraction et de l'état la question
de la question n'est pas là la question
est aujourd'hui que en fait
cette modification légale effectivement
a bouleversé la donne nous ne comprenons
pas aujourd'hui les assiettes et les
mais les modes de de cotisation de
calcul et surtout surtout le je dirais
le fait de base est un impôt sur autre
chose que ce qui est aujourd'hui
je dirais le
le rendement des entreprises
c'est-à-dire les bénéfices des
entreprises est quelque chose qui ne
nous semble pas juste mais aujourd'hui
si on revenait par exemple à la taxe
professionnelle telle qu'elle existait
avant en 2009 vous payeriez plus ou
moins qu'aujourd'hui - beaucoup - la
taxe professionnelle pesé moins lourd
pour les entreprises et les quartiers
même si effectivement au niveau 2 les
cas ce qu'il nous était dit que cela
représentait en général une baisse
d'environ 80% mais la réalité est tout
autre et c'est assez surprenant que
lorsque l'on discute avec des
entreprises les chiffres qui nous sont
donnés par ces entrepreneurs par ces
artisans par ces indépendants ne
correspondent pas du tout à ce qui
ressort des chiffres annoncés par la
caisse qui donc effectivement il y à une
dichotomie entre les deux et je j'ai
tendance plus à
m'intéresser à la réalité du terrain qui
elle ne se contente pas de chiffres qui
songe à dire sorti d'on ne sait où donc
la solution aujourd'hui qui est proposé
c'est de payer 1 d'ici au 15 décembre
c'est la date qui a été fixée légalement
pour s'acquitter de cet impôt c'est de
payer la même somme qu'en 2011 la suite
sera échelonnée tout au long des
prochains mois il semblerait pouvoir
être une solution s le brésilien
s'avance et logis fait pas parce que ce
que vous souhaitez c'est la réduction
bien sûr c'est un double président cas
d'albert clairement annoncé aujourd'hui
il va je crois faire un communiqué de
presse complémentaires par rapport à ça
que les entreprises piron au 15 décembre
ce qu'elles payaient l'année dernière
reste maintenant un différentiel qui
peut être très important comme nous
venons de le signaler là la discussion
est engagée nous de notre côté nous
disons très clairement que c'est une
décision politique de la casse qui il y
à certaines il y a bien sûr un
environnement légal il y avait fication
de loi il y as vu ce qui s'est passé ces
dernières années mais très clairement
aujourd'hui le conseil de
l'agglomération et maître des décisions
qu'il peut prendre en matière de
pourcentage et vous leur demander de
baisser de revenir revenir sur le taux
de leurs calculs et que vous payez mois
faut simplement comme l'amendement qui a
été voté au sénat tout récemment permet
justement
besoin de recettes en ciel le sois là si
elle le souhaite à nouveau de délibérer
sur la question est donc de revenir à
l'état l'état initial je dirais et si
jamais vous n'obtenez pas ce que vous
souhaitez nouvelle mobilisation
exceptionnelle quarantaine cinquantaine
ça tu as pris ta face à saint quentin en
yvelines dans les rues oui pour une
bonne et simple raison c'est que il a
fallu organiser cela très très
rapidement d'autant plus que nous avions
une inquiétude si le fait que nous à
dire nous avons les impôts à payer au 15
décembre donc ça nous laisse est très
très peu de délai devant nous il est
vrai que là on a une réunion qui est
prévu non pas entre nous mais au niveau
de la caisse qui pour le 20 décembre et
nous aurons effectivement l'occasion de
pouvoir ré intervenir si nécessaire
dans l'immédiat le président donc de la
casse qui monsieur cadalbert s'est
engagée à titre personnel a essayé de
faire revenir le taux de la cfa ou tout
du moins la base de calcul qui était
monté au niveau de 6000 alors que
l'année dernière encore une fois nous
étions en 1093 je prends mon exemple
personnel mais qui s'applique à beaucoup
d'entreprises et s'est engagé à le faire
revenir à la moyenne des yvelines et il
nous indiquait que cela représentait un
niveau de 2000 donc déjà nous aurions
fait un très grand pas en avant pas
nécessairement ce que nous recherchons
tous je veux dire les uns les autres no
- déjà un grand pas serait franchi et
effectivement il nous a assuré avoir
contacté donc à l'hôtel des impôts pour
lui pour indiquer justement qu'il
souhaitait que seule la l'équivalent de
l'acf qui avaient été payés l'année
dernière soit à payer pour le 15
décembre et le reste le reste à payer
serait à prévoir une fois que la
décision de la casse qui serait
définitive on verra comment évoluera ce
dossier dans les prochaines semaines ce
sera très rapide puisqu'il faut bien
évidemment s'acquitter de cet impôt
forcément il ya toujours un délai elles
les gars merci à vous d'être venu nous
expliquer vos revendications et vous
restez mobilisés l'avait dit
éventuellement d'autres manifestations à
suivre pour obtenir cet allégement de la
cotisation financière des entreprises un
chemin de la laïcité inaugure à
guyancourt après le rond-point des
droits de l'homme la rue de la liberté
la place de la fraternité sous cela
semble bien logique reportage un
kilomètre de laïcité inauguré à
guyancourt le chemin pédestre jusqu
alors sans appellation a profité de la
journée nationale de la laïcité se faire
un nom le 9 décembre c'est la date
anniversaire de la de la loi sur la
séparation des églises et de l'état mais
c'est aussi la date a été choisie par le
sénat et le texte de loi va maintenant
aller à l'assemblée pour faire de cette
date le 9 décembre la journée nationale
de la laïcité un véritable symbole pour
la ville de guyancourt qui dispose déjà
d'un rond-point des droits de l'homme
d'une rue de la liberté et d'une place
de la fraternité
chemin parce que vous savez la laïcité
c'est une conquête ce sont bien sûr des
valeurs celles de de liberté de
conscience et celle de vivre ensemble
mais c'est aussi une conquête et le
chemin représente bien cette image de
conquête le chemin de la laïcité permet
de se balader entre le quartier des
garennes et celui des saules tout près
des bâtiments universitaires vauban et
d'alembert